second part of my talk so this is joint
work with Mei and major care and Luka
Reggio and the starting point of this
work is the quest to understand what
should be identities and how one could
obtain identities for varieties of
possibly non regular languages and this
is really a little bit of a baby step in
that direction so we try to understand
this inductively and the first step was
to understand what corresponds to one
certain operation on language at the
level of the recognizer for for that
language so the first thing in my talk
will be to recall a duality approach or
a language recognition
there was a lot of work in this
direction starting with an icon paper
from 2008 of Mayors anorectal and Sergey
Gregorio
but I'm going to explain to you it to
you in slowly and in a way that we have
described it in as rather equivalent
Wayne an icon paper for this year in
2016 and then as an example I will show
you a construction that one has on mano
it's and also on the notion of
recognizer that we have namely syntactic
spaces that corresponds to exists
naturally quantified language and we
call this the you know reshoots and
Persia product because it it really
looks like the fruits and Persia product
done for concatenation of languages
and the third bit in my talk will be
about trying to understand why this
actually works and because I like
category theory quite a lot it turned
out that I've seen at some code density
Mona's going on and popping into this
into the picture and I think that this
is the thing that we did in this I call
paper with Melaleuca can be generalized
to understand a wider family of
operations on languages in terms of this
liftings of monads some those spaces
with some more noise that I will that
this will come up in a bit so in order
to explain point one I need a short a
very brief preliminary on finite duality
so this is a very simple theorem that I
think I expect everyone knows especially
those that have attended mass clock you
know Friday namely that the categories
of finite boolean algebras and the
category of finite sets are dually
equivalent and if I start with a finite
boolean algebra I obtain a finite set by
taking its atoms and in the converse
direction I take the power set of a set
so this gives me an equipment reality
between this these two categories if I
start I mean there is another very
simple duality theorem theorem stating
that the category of sets is dually
equivalent to the category of complete
atomic boolean algebras so just as
before those boolean algebras that can
be obtained as the power set of a set
are precisely those that are complete
and atomic and the factors are described
in the same way so once once we know
these two results I can explain very
quickly what is the syntactic knowledge
have a space in the light of this
duality
if I start with a language in some
alphabet a I can consider a boolean
algebra which is spanned by the
quotients of this language so I take two
words I mean I take all the DS quotients
and that's been a boolean algebra if the
languages happens to be regular then I
know that this boolean algebra is finite
so I have a morphism of well actually
it's a moment of complete atomic boolean
algebra so because and now because we
know jollity theory we know that
whenever we have such an embedding of
complete atomic boolean algebra if we
flip if we go to the duo category namely
to the category of sets we have that the
atoms of the power set of a star from
this set of atoms we have a subjective
map to the atoms of this boolean algebra
meal what are the atoms of this power
set they are just the words a star so
this is a morphism
yes I have and this is an injection so
here I have a surjection
but moreover observe that on this
boolean algebra of languages I have an
action of the of the mono it of words
because there are quotients so I can
quote on to the left and to the right
and this dysmorphia sphere is not just a
morphism incomplete atomic boolean
algebra but furthermore it is amorphous
that preserves this action of a star on
the boolean algebra and moreover for
each for each word if I look at the left
action of this world on the boolean
algebra basis this is in fact a boolean
algebra morphism so by Diala t it
so that this this map with a distraction
that I obtained inset is also a morphism
of continual firm of actions of a star
of two-sided compatible actions of a
star so this also preserves
the actions of a star on respectively on
a star which is moderate and on this on
the set of atoms so what we obtain is
that this Vicente bottoms so it is very
simple lemma that if I have such a
subjective map from a mono it and here I
have actions of the mono it on this set
that this thing becomes a mono it and in
fact it is the syntactic knowledge of
the language so one can obtain the
synthetic moremore unless that bit more
freedom of a language just by by duality
so now what happens if I well they have
a mono in structure which which they get
right from this from from from a star
and it turns out I mean it's a simple
computation is not like it becomes it is
a simple computation to show that this
is indeed the syntactic ma knowing that
one obtains with the usual definition so
if one drops the regularity condition on
the language what happens is that the
boolean algebra here is no longer finite
so the morphism is no longer in complete
atomic boolean algebras so this business
with atoms is no longer really useful so
we have to use a fancier duality theorem
which i will write on this this is i so
this is the preliminary may be sure it
gets visible if i it's visible if i
write it like down here so i have the
category of is anyway it's just the
standard stone jollity theorem if you
don't know it i don't have the time to
actually explain the founders but the
point is that if you start with a
boolean algebra instead of the atoms one
would have to consider the set of ultra
filters
and then to come up with a topology on
this set of ultra filters which is
compact hausdorff and moreover zero
dimensions if it has a basis of globins
and conversely if one has such a
topological space and considers the set
of its clopin then this one has a
structure of boolean algebras so roughly
this is this is the stone duality so
instead of of looking at the atoms so
this is embedding sting in holds here I
have a boolean algebra which is not
going to be finite and here what I will
do
I will have to look at the dual of the
powers that of a star which are the
ultra filters here so it's the star J
compactification of a star and I will
have a quotient to the ultra filters of
the boolean algebra generated by oh
let's call this excel so and again here
the actions of a star on the boolean
algebra BL can be realized
so I will get left and right compatible
actions of a star on the space excel and
this map so this is a continuous
function this one also preserves the the
two sided actions of a star and one can
ask okay so where is this interacting
mono in all this business well recall
that I have an embedding of a star in
the principal ultra filters so each word
here will be mapped to the principal
ultra filter it generates and if i
factor this embedding
I get one set here that also has
inherits the two-sided a actions of the
mano a day star and therefore it it is a
mano it a quotient of waste are and
after a few computations one can verify
that M is indeed the syntactic mono it
and the lack of the language but using
it alone for recognition is not is not
sufficient so because here you need so
in order to retrieve so of course this
this mono and morphism will recognize l
but if you if you allow to use as a
recognizer said any subset of them
you'll get much much more languages so
to be able to recognize exactly the
boolean algebra of quotients one would
have to use the claw points the traces
of the claw points in your topology so
this is where the topology on the dual
is actually used so we can
define I mean from from this from this
picture one can distill what would be a
local right notion of recognizer in the
case of a language which is not
necessarily regular and we come up with
the following definition we own or stone
space I'm going to use this with an
eternal moment
it's such a pair where X is a boolean
space tourists on space and included in
X is a dance morning
X has two-sided compatible actions and
such that each component of these
actions
I'm sorry a stone space so I have read
unfortunately rich Joe stones book
before meeting me who insist on calling
them boolean spaces so so if I say
boolean space is the same a stone space
I'm sorry for going but or historically
speaking if they should be called
boolean spaces no well yes may the
expert make I think yes so the answer
yeah so and then we can say when a
language so a language L in a star is
recognized by such space with an
internal model it provided that one has
a commutative diagram of this shape
where here I have I have a mono it so
this y is really the same and there
exists a clopin in s such that the
language L is five minus one of
intersected with that so this is really
the notion of recognition which appears
in in a slightly different form in in
the work of a generic and Sergey
grigoriev and this is a reformulation of
it in this is something we came up with
in in this cycle paper so now it's time
to go maybe very quickly to the second
point namely how do we deal with
existential quantifiers and how do we
see an action of
how do we translate the existential
quantifier into an operation on this on
this category of stone or boolean spaces
so the question is the following maybe I
have some some logical formula with one
free first-order variable and I have a
language an expanded alphabet that
corresponds to this to this formula Phi
and what now if I have the language l
exists let's try this as a shortcut for
the language that corresponds to the
existential quantifier formula the
question that we try to ask hints to
answer is if we if we have a more way
that recognizes L Phi then how can we
recognize this this exists and the
answer that we came up with is not the
block product is people usually do in
this area but we say okay so let's say
that L Phi is recognized by this by this
morphism let's let's take first the
regular case to keep it at the moment
to explain it Adam on wheat first and
then we lifter the the the argument to
two spaces well then one can consider I
mean the way with we do it one can
consider really a transformation it's a
transduction in fact so to each word we
associate the set of words which have
one marked position so this this
notation spends for for the same for the
same letters in a but here I can either
a zero and the one and this means that I
have exactly one one in in my word so
for example just to a B will be sent to
the set a 0 B 0 a 1 B 0 sorry is the one
I mark exactly one one letter so once I
have I have access to the words that
have exactly one marking I can okay I
obtain here morphism from a star to the
power set of M which recognizes mine in
my language L exists but it is not a
mono in morphism because this is not a
relational morphus so I have to do
something something tricky here one
option would be to represent this
distillation between the words in a star
and the words in a x 2 star in terms of
a mono it morphism using a
representation of of of this
transduction as I mean the realization
of this relation using this thing so
this transducer realizes this relation
and from here one of things that the
relation are factors through a monoid
morphism so I have a model in morphism
where I'm using matrix of it's a matrix
representation of this relation that is
the two here stands for the fact that I
have a two-state transducer this is will
be generated by a being mapped this
matrix and if we apply here
the morphism phi one gets a mono it
morphism which exactly recognizes and
exists and what is nice about this story
which becomes a bit technical is that it
lifts very easily to the case of two to
the recognizers to these Breton risers
involving stone spaces with internal
models so we won one recognizer that one
obtains I mean we we still can see here
that in fact is these factors through a
semi direct product of of M and the
finite power set of M
so that is that L exists recognized by a
mano it morphism from a star to a
product of M and the finite power but
now this is so if a phallus would be
regular if I'd be in the regular case
that would be fine but I am NOT in the
regular case necessarily so what would
be a stone space with an internal mono
it that recognizes and exists so if L if
my original language L is recognized by
a pair X M then L exists will be
recognized by a space with an internal
modeling that is carried by the
following topological space or on the
topological site I have a product of X
and V a torus of X which is in some
sense a generalization of of the power
set to the category of stone spaces and
this mono it that I have described
before briefly which sits inside this
space so one can explain this directly
in terms of duality theory so one can
take the boolean algebra generated by L
exists computes the left-right quotients
and get at some point the dual of this
via Taurus on some boolean algebra so
the action of the mono it powers at of M
times M on this space comes up extremely
natural from a duality theoretic
computation but it also seems that we
can try to understand
this the more conceptual level like
we're I mean okay this this setting
works fine for the existential
quantifier but what if I want to to
understand some other operations for
example a modular accounting quantifier
so I want to define a language this is
sorry the number of positions so if I if
I mark those positions in my word I get
a word in L so in this the number of
positions certain the markings is in L
should be congruent with 2 modulo 3 so
if I if I have such a definition of an
existential quantifier can I do a
similar a similar job can i and of
course one can try to redo all the
computations from the beginning but it's
also interesting to observe that instead
of using the power set here one can try
to replace it with another so instead of
using the power set which I see as a
moment I use another monent
corresponding to that's three semi
modules so instead of having this
relation from a star to power set of a
times to star I want a relation from a
star to all the finitely supported
functions from a x 2 star to Z 3 and now
if I go to
2:03 2m I obtained again amorphous which
recognizes the language L exists so the
picture seems to work fine for mono is I
mean again this transduction can be
represented as a matrix I get a mono
amorphous this part generalizes nicely
but what do I do if I want to go beyond
the regular case if I want to live to
these operations to stone spaces with
with internal mono it's and the answer
is what this for me was on the second
board is disco density monad story
because it turns out that the operation
that we had here this bar torus is
essentially obtained from the power set
in the following way
I mean one way of looking at it is as
follows
so
I look at the island Berg more algebras
for for the powerset which are finitely
carried so this would be finite choice a
metathesis I forget about the algebra
structure and I see the these finite
sets as equipped with a discrete
topology so and this works more
generally for any set motor so this one
so a finite set is a stone space okay
nothing betting this is the forgetful
founder so these are all number more
algebras forty which are finitely
carried forgetful found term so let's
call this one
I don't know J so if I look
uh no I mean it works in general but it
I mean there are some aspects of this
theory which would work much better if
these closed tip reserves finite sets
but of course I mean the construction
that I will use here this this code
density monad for this factor so this is
obtained as the right kind extension of
J along J of course this will kneel the
same thing if I start with the finite
power set or with the whole power set so
in a sense this is the part of the Monad
which which is interesting so the point
is that every for every but for this
construction works in general because
the the right context nation is computed
point wise because stone is a very nice
category oh I'm sorry
yes two minutes I'm done so one we have
this this extension of the monad T to
stone spaces for every Monat and we have
also that whenever T is commutative set
Mona I won't have time to explain what
that commutative means but I can tell
you later
then he has a canonical lifting to the
category of monoliths so let's call this
T bar
or the powerset is just saying that the
power set of em has a canonical mono
eight structure given by complex
multiplication so I'm probably it's best
to end with the commutative said Mora
and exam is the stone space with an
internal mono it then G hat of X where t
hat is this extension of t2 to stone
spaces and TM is again a stone space
with internal modes what I'm cheating a
bit because actually one has a map of TM
into TX so we should probably look at
the image of that map but modulo a
little bit of sloppiness this theorem is
it's fine if T is the power set or the
fine furniture power set then so I want
to apply this case I get exactly what I
have told you about for the existential
quantifier when one can do this for for
any commutative semi-ring and for the
corresponding semi semi module reason a
modular monad and this gives a kind of a
general recipe for obtaining recognizers
for for example for all the languages of
this shape given by modulo counting
quantifiers and more generally one can
think of other examples like turning or
an arbitrary monads T I mean any
Kreisler map from a star to B star for
that mo not one to transform languages
on B stars to languages on on a star but
of course there are many more things to
be understood in in this setting like
how one can obtain this computation from
a duality theoretic point of view and
finding lots of interesting examples
where this is actually useful and then
of course the difficult step
understanding how to obtain ultra filter
equations and how to actually put this
machinery to use for for some more
practical purposes so I should stop on
this note so thanks for the Chinese take
a very few questions valves of negatory
question what happens when yeah I think
yes I not familiar with it but I can
imagine what I can tell you is that the
moon and also leads to commutative
monoid snow this this framework should
should also work in that in that setting
an example of how powerful this is even
though she does know perixx theorem she
can assure you that it works
some of these classes of languages are
closed
complementation and what does it come to
I mean can you characterize properties
of strong space in which this works or
that I'd have to think but yeah I think
that's not something that can be done
yeah yeah I think it's offline because I
guess my questions do they ask you for
some intuition in the definition of
Stoke space with internal one or at the
last boss was continuity at each
component mm-hmm so it seems to me that
that means you define the motor in
action sort of completely independently
and all the components use the accent of
choice to pick completely the end of
things and it would still be ok is that
how should I understand that well I mean
first of all they are not completely
independent the way the ones that
actually come from constraint that is I
would expect there was you did forget
one
I mean you didn't mention one property
in the definition namely that on the
internal mana it has to actually be more
annoyed multiplication yes I mean that
the mow it in sideways no but the more
interim or beyond the individual
components that's where my intuition is
following up no no so I think yeah but
the motor it is dance inside and inside
the SpaceX so this already gives a
little bit of yeah that's what I don't
it gives a little bit but you know I
don't you know the density helps if you
don't have continuity
on the part that's inside em itself you
know what it has to be yeah it's been
put in training at most one come one
continuation to the whole space saying
it's semi topological I'm good but it's
semi topological the mono exists in this
space and it acts in a semi topological
fashion stuff okay we can stop the
detective here thanks very much